com arena qui sera derrière la dernière
un commentaire pendant un petit moment
mais on en reparlera plus tard je vais
attendre que vous arriviez pour vous
parler de tout ça aujourd'hui on va
jouer en échec 960 le phisheur vandomme
avec la position des pièces qui est
tirée au sort pour varier un petit peu
les plaisirs
au moins on n'aura pas à se soucier de
la théorie sais pas si je vais jouer
avec vous jusqu'au monter vos parties je
vais attendre déjà que vous arriviez
petit à petit salut top chef est ce que
tu peux me dire c'est pour l'instant
l'image est bonne il n'y a pas de lag
pas de décalage parce qu'hier eu des
petits bugs pendant les premières
minutes puis ensuite se stabiliser
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui tout ira bien ok
parfait
est ce que tu joues l'aube chess
l'instant voilà six inscrits on commence
dans un dans un quart d'heure ouais bon
jour 960 bâtir aussi en la position des
pièces
ça nous change un petit peu et beaucoup
d'armes classiques 3 plus de sa luminox
42 si vous voulez jouer vous mets le
lien
la double et big fish fait des soldats
qui sont en train d'oublier une petite
coupe russes pouvaient donc plus de 3000
comme je disais au début dans les jours
à venir d'un petit peu accessible le
stream de 13 art vais plus tard mois
vous verrez qu'on fait ça du coup un
petit essoufflement
c'est bien de varier les plaisirs on
proposera plein d'autres contenus on
continuera d'organiser le tournoi mais
peut-être que les stream seront moins
régulier ouais si tu reprends vers 13h30
ça va être juste tu pourras faire deux
parties si tu veux
rescue télétravail qui peuvent laisser
emporter par l'élan du jeu ce qu'il voit
bah vous allez me dire si vous préférez
que je peux m'en nouveau parti vous
distribuer mes points sachant que chaque
960 je dois pas avoir de l eau
j'imagine que peu d'entre vous au ciel
dans ces cas là ils doivent au début
peut-être considéré les lots de blitz
pas exactement comment sa vache
un stream pédagogique et jeu a priori ce
sera le grand retour de vlad donc
j'imagine que vous serez peut-être
nombreux qui sera là avec kevin
alors on commence à 1200 partout warta
hockey tels que j'ai déjà fait quelques
échecs nous sont 68 ans je me souviens
pas je vérifierai ça donc quand elle ce
soir je crois que c'est à partir de 19
heures que cave sera avec avec vlad
pour son grand retour si tout va bien
ouais c'est longtemps acquis des bases à
l'antenne de trois mois je crois ou pour
des parties pédagogique avec vous ça lui
nahed pour l'instant top belwind vous
avez l'habitude un petit peu vous en
faites de temps en temps ou pas de
richard van damme c'est vraiment
exceptionnel
je pense que je n'ai pas joué depuis
plusieurs années salut marquer les
premiers
donc
au moins une dizaine de minutes le temps
que la reine se remplissent du coup tu
es plutôt un théoricien la pièce salut
sky mobile a priori cette variante qui
favorise quand même les joueurs dont le
répertoire est léger un peu créatifs et
à l'état de forme du moment donc sur qui
compte aussi pour voir le cerveau bien
rêver c'est pas facile
il salue la beuverie qui ont des guides
tellement les grandes man gignac a
inscrit aussi blague
bencheikh julien bianchi a fini médaille
d'argent hier me semble c'est une bonne
question
tu me poses la kwarta c'est une
excellente réponse de pleutres alors
jusqu'à il ya deux mois jallet match
espace pour être honnête je les lui
quand même pendant un temps mais ensuite
pendant plusieurs années n'ont autant
dire que j'avais trop de fichiers
d'ouverture après pour mes élèves
lâcheté des efforts en six saisons
besoin de bosser sur un truc spécifié
que le fait pour eux mais pas pour moi
c'est l'image du coup c'est pour toi
avec jesse schell 970 jours plus tôt à
lantin
tu vas pas être tactiquement c'est
embêtant c'est vrai que du coup cette
variante de par la position atypique des
pièces peut-être créer des thèmes
tactique fréquents l'avion si vous avez
suivi un peu le championnat du monde
ganso
j'avais d'autres mais la finale c'est
carlton sont les parties étaient
vraiment hyper spectaculaire il sole qui
avait d'ailleurs rougis les fesses de
magnus là c'était une grosse fait cela
qui va nous obliger ce avait surpris
tout le monde moi le premier d'ailleurs
salut dragons chez plus quel était le
score il y avait plusieurs cadres au
genou qui avait dans un système de
points particuliers mais c'était genre
du 15 3 pour bourse au salut pour le
pied aussi de faire sens avec ta
présence de public data
alors du coup droit si vous préférez que
donc je joue votre commande vous partir
moi ça m'est égal
non c'est plus reposant l'adoption
triple r c'est pas courant finale dans
cette position et du coup qui devrait
assurer la victoire
après ça va p'tet ce jeu autant sur le
carreau à djibo filiales et blanc ici
encore qu'est-ce que etc les noirs on
peut harceler le roi le roi blanc ajusta
à venir se cacher faire dame et du coup
y aura d'autres pions pour remplacer
celui sur lequel la tour sera sacrifié
la série commençait cette triplette à
lui frank zappa des conseils pour les
960 bah franchement
prenez un petit peu de temps car le
second a plus non plus un gros premier
coup à la limite pour essayer de bien
cerner les enjeux de la position par
rapport aux placements des pièces et
tout de suite avoir un plan pour le rock
je vous rappelle que juste pas avoir de
pièce entre et normalement on peut faire
tirant comme grand vainqueur
ouais moi aussi en forme n'a pas les
petits problèmes de serveurs cette amp
cie dimanche d'un black hat a d'ailleurs
salué des volailles pour un salaire
stable aujourd'hui
le centre savez bon enfin du coup ça
peut être très bizarre des fois il peut
y avoir des parties peut faire des
menaces au premier mot genre où nous
tout symptôme ça prouvera diagonale
d'une dame qui va menacer d'aller manger
un pion à l'autre bout pour faire très
attention de bureau fait parfois on va
privilégier un jeu sur une aire pourquoi
pas c'est un peu atypique après choix
malgré tous les efforts je m'en retourne
dans des schémas qui leur ressemble à
des ouvertures plus classique salluste
hasek et salue abdel donc du coup 960
c'est particulier faites-la pardonne pas
si vous n'êtes pas réveillé au début
vous essayez de vous pouvez perdre
antique où ça c'est tout à fait vrai
publie naters est plus dans le roi de la
colline que le centre l hyper important
parce qu'on veut privilégier un un
chemin pour notre roi et sais qui tu
laisses jaurès je ne sais pas
je sais je pensais que ce serait avec de
la reine fête du boeuf
je veux qu'un joueur très créatif car
mon avis pour le coup de très très très
doués ou en 960 la vie on peut pas se
préparer on se résout wenger salue le
gars fabergé sky bobby parce que là
comme son nom l'indiqué à 960 positions
possibles au départ donc là c'est
compliqué de tout anticiper bien tu
perds c'est un peu à l'instinct
honnêtement je trouve que dans cette
variante l'instinct très important je
suis bien d'accord plutôt 14 ans que
globalement ça va renverser des échecs
960 remplacer les déchets classiques
jeux pour arriver au parti allait
tranquillement embêtant réveiller cinq
minutes avant par inquiète me prendre
une prépa serait la belle vie
malheureusement ça marche pas comme ça
ouais l'instant exacerbée et là je vais
m'inscrire jamais inscrit là je vous
distribuer de mes points bien
généreusement croyants ont pu l'être
quelques choix de finitions jamais de
joe biden pour le bo sachant que les
rares fois geste raymond jours s'est
très mal passé au niveau tu es loin
s'est très bien passé pour mes
adversaires mais fit celle de faire
mieux aujourd'hui
je pense que ça ne compte pas pour le
classement dormard stade cheikh
normalement ça doit ça doit compter pour
les chèques 960 même si l'asse au niveau
normal qui va apparaître au début où
1200 je sais pas ce sera la surprise
c'est trop
hyper bull est là c'est la boucherie en
as tu essaies de jouer les sacrifices du
bûcheron fous ces quatre faut prendre un
set j'ai eu des retraits pour extraire
le roi ouais mais 2006 ans a rempli le
gaffeur obligé en échec 960 j'ai
clairement pas de 1600 j'ai pas dû jouer
alors il ya très longtemps
on verra ça lui alex et j'ai vu il n'ya
pas mon temps justement il y avait il y
avait un match entre leïla regard la
phase héros et c'est un fish et un
article sur une chaise comme là dessus
et je crois qu'il y avait eu quelque
chose comme 106 à 94 pour leïla
stockfisch allait définitivement terrel
ouais exactement marconnet
le client de tendre à ça me fait plaisir
ah je pense qu'elles changeraient pas
mal de choix horaire déjà on a vu un le
match dont je parlais tout à l'heure où
il ya eu zéro car celle qu'ils ont pas
su en demi finale je sais plus et
peut-être d'impôts je suis un peu du 4e
mais où sow a complètement des boîtes
car c'était très heureuse surprise que
justement si on avait l'impression que
le style un peu plus et partie
soporifique pour moi vraiment juste si
je dois commenté une partie de deux
sauts lente je suis rousse faire à
l'avancé quoi il va rien se passer est
très heureux de faire nul et
les manceaux avaient marché sur
quinzaine comme va commencer dans une
minute donc sous très fort a priori d'un
cap ou un bougeoir 960 o'shea nespouls
j'imagine un but comme il est créatif
allez hop jazz qui nous rejoint donc
ouais ça peut le faire serait plein de
choses et surtout au niveau du coude et
prépare les seconds ans retrouvée au
chômage en fait assez sympa comme
s'allonge perceval le premier qui à 960
lots gagnants dans un bois de mont
diamand vous arriver à finir 1960 et
l'eau un four de la reine le bien vous
promettre un abonnement d amour je
m'arrangerais mais c'est pas
je pense être très précis et on va
commencer dans cinq secondes
bonne chance à tous je vous souhaite de
jouer contre eux croit et on commence
avec n'a alors pas fou je réfléchisse un
peu au moins appuyé sur le départ je
vous en 3 + 2 alors je vais ouvrir une
diagonale déjà peut pas être mauvais des
fonds sont pions pas facile
cette pièce l'impression d'avoir joué à
la roulette russe las vegas c'est bien
joué de sa part je pense j'ai pas trop
comment se sortir des pièges
j'ai tendance à vouloir beaucoup
réfléchir au début est de lui qu ici on
clique mg pas sur laquelle casa par ten
mes pièces plutôt reprendre d'une pions
ici je prends des cavaliers l'apprendre
le sens ça va être assez désagréable
même site est créé une pression sur
quatre on va avoir c'est toujours un 3
pouces de haut de chaque 960 on est
obligé de lui très vite alors que la
position objectivement demanderai quand
même réflexion en les péchés de matt
hackett sur g7 il le fait parce que je
défends dieu j'ai pas forcément hyper
envie de jouer même si j'aurais pu jouer
avec g6 mais du coup kg cité peut-être
pas ouf alors l'impression de déjà
perdre le fil n'est pas très bon signe
selon vous ces sept c'est pas une vraie
menace ou proches d'eux - jacques thibon
vous en faites mondiale plus de celle de
l'échangé de l'oeuf ou est ce un contre
110 dans la grande diagonale est assez
fort si je vois rien si je fais ça
j'aurais j'aurai vingt sept dans l'air à
la fin
reste que je peux manger son cavalier
m'agresse d'entre elles n'aiment pas le
temps de me chauffer de mettre dans le
bain ticket j'avais envie
faut 5 mais je peux pas assez
désagréable se trouve peut-être mangeant
des simples mais à chaud rockets un jour
si je rends je me prends une fourchette
espère la dame convoi royal j'étais je
vais manger ça me scie est un peu sans
même réfléchir à la suite à mu était
complètement con manger en fait j'ai g7
en l'air à la fois ces cadors comme
promis je ne vois absolument absolument
rien je vais quand même jouer ça du coup
pour limiter la casse est moins grave de
perdre option que de perdre g7 mais pour
l'instant ça se passe très délicatement
pour moi le tireur qui avait cavaliers
pros mais cette fourchette je perdais la
dame
j'ai perdu un pion et il appert de fou
après c'est peut-être pas si dramatique
ne veut on va retomber dans une position
plus logique fois créé deux joueurs ok
peut-être je peux avoir un peu de jeu
avec madame on est juste un tournoi en
fait alarmant il est mieux après j'ai
quand même quelques compensations pour
la colonne scène ça pour me pour me
rassurer mme en réalité on va y étais
j'ai pas grand chose et c'est très bien
joué de sa part même je vais b5
elle a sans doute joué des f4 on le met
madame on sait trois rayons retour b3
ouais pas très convaincu par cette
position je vais essayer de faire parler
la force du cheval etc une fourchette de
derrière les fagots au monde
il avait 2 canal est en fait il y avait
deux cavaliers donc il y avait bien la
fourchette en deux sets
après le tirage c'est un des rares truc
que j'avais vu même si je suis pas hyper
fan j'ai quand même joué pour rayer un
tempo sur la dame fait de [ __ ] c'était
le muscle e-class tout l'espace insiste
sur scène d'activer un peu je voulais
faire une flèche
une fois je me laisse une case de rugby
mais cet effet sont tombés 5 gênant donc
là vraiment je suis plutôt très mal dans
cette position batta cassette
j'ai vu et je paie tam csn pour des
prendre un petit point avec son pion ces
deux pour l'instant mais il devrait
pouvoir le résoudre à mon cavalier je
vais quand même si je verrai ce qui peut
prendre
il peut prendre enfermé saddam dont
j'oublie terre j 6 il n'était pas prévu
puisque c'est une très mauvaise chose
pour mon cavalier
j'ai encore très mal calculé j'ai plus
de 18 secondes c'est d'arrêter de parler
je devais des meilleurs coups mais à
chaque coup je dégrade un peu plus ma
position
j'espère que vous appréciez tiens mes
promesses c'est lui faire ça je vais
changer les dames
s'il accepte
j'aurais quand même dû contre jeu sur la
colonne c'est le problème c'est le
cavalier qui pour l'instant est vraiment
dégueulasse angers 6 parce que toutes
ces cas son contrôle elle refuse
l'échangé d'armes s'il est bien dommage
pas faire çà et là à 7
mais j'ai envie de faire des coups
active même s'ils sont mauvais
j'aimerais contre-attaqué mais j'arrive
par lui il le prend il n'a pas peur la
raison j'aimerais faire des trucs avec
ce cavalier mais j'arrive pas je laisse
tomber dessus
sam c'est le tilt j'essayais de faire
des trucs sur son roi mais objectivement
ça va être très bonne nouvelle je suis
déjà en dessous de 4 et une demie partie
ce qui est assez prometteur parce que
qu'il est probable 4 une menace non
qu'elle allait elle chute mais c'est
d'une tristesse infinie comme coup on
déforme 17 ballons du coup il veut
changer les dames banon je suis plus
d'accord
j'ai deux pions de moins alors jet set
qui est toujours super faible
il ya quand même aussi quelques quelques
cibles j'ai cette seconde voie bien ils
attaquent nos pions faible je veux 6
prendre du cavalier bizarrement n'avait
toujours pas activé son fou pour
l'instant mais dès l'instant son fou
entre en jeu un match très mal c'est
bien de jouer en jeu
mais cette option ne l'est plus je vais
finalement prendre comme ça je change
d'avis voilà j'avais annoncé que dès que
l'on vous activerez je serai très mal je
ce fait je continue de me faire glisser
en plus c'est 'je veux cinq un jour mais
mais c'est pas gagné
je donne tout mais lucho c'est le
carnage il force des changes des dames
ce qu'il me donne une très mauvaise
nouvelle
merci de les garder mais je vais faire
je vais me faire un petit peu et font
c'est ici voilà ça j'avais j'ai vu aux
gens et je pense que l'abandon voilà
bugue l'abandon bravo ina aide c'était
la démonte à la en direct belle partie
j'espère que vous allez apprécier
je suis en gagner une et d'être moins
généreux du modèle points et si je vais
plus vite aussi
maintenant j'ai du retard vraiment
compliqué alors est ce qu'on a on va pas
voir tout le temps à la diposition la
même position le cerveau n'est vraiment
pas rêver c'était très très dur je vois
absolument aucune tactique je suis cool
d'échec 960 c'est pas la meilleure
décider pour moi aller
le départ diesel voyage réfléchir moi
j'essaie de prendre le centre en m'en
donnait si pour l'instant c'est bien
contrôler regardez un peu le chat c'est
dur de commandes s'est en même temps way
et le tour de chauffe ouais merci vous
êtes gentil ça fait perdre pas mal de
temps facebook commenté mais bon ça fait
partie du jeu ici surtout j'ai donné
beaucoup trop de camps je prédis faire
plus attention
alors ça se passe plutôt bien cette
ouverture je vais quand même un fort
centre est plutôt passif ici qu'à
monnaie il faut trouver un plan mois
charm-el-cheikh j'essaie de retrouver
juste une position assez classique avec
mes deux photos braqués sur son roi je
vais assez le grand roque du coup a par
principe depuis maintenant je veux je
suis et d'ouvrir au centre d'une façon
ou d'une autre
ainsi ce qui va limiter qu'à monnaie
donc pour ok donc votre roi vous
l'amener sur la casse de notre tour ça
vous fait le coup automatiquement si
vous avez un doute je vais l'a empêché
de venir m'embêter avec son cavalier
et là il fait le prendre comme s'ils
allaient des cinq façons c'est une arène
faut jouer à 7,8
quitte à faire des mauvais coups est-ce
que destin que c'était un peu précipité
si j'aurais préféré prendre du cavalier
mais il ya eu 4 qui enlève donc vraiment
niveau calcul c'est zéro je vais prendre
une fois je vais jouer cavalier des
quatre là ça commence à bien se passer
pour moi avec mes pièces qui
s'harmonisent vers son roi et je ramène
ma d'avancé 4 il est sage 3g c'est pas
grave au droit qui m'intéresse le ciel
je sens qu'il ya une espèce de bel abbès
dans mon cerveau ça se bouscule
mais il voit pas grand chose tu paries
chellah pleuvry je vois que ça se passe
bien déjà super ça se passe bien pour
vous monsieur k remarquerez le naturel
de mon jeune alors la vie et le dessin
ou pas qu'il y ait des 5
that is the creation and the 5 aussi
pour ouvrir mon enfant cavalier e 6 pour
gagner la paire de fond un peu trop de
bons coups ici
j'ai pas convaincu de cavaliers des 5
je vais quand même j'aime prendre de la
dame j'ai de faire des petits pièges
adha dans la grande diagonale sur
bessette et du le 5 voix si elle bat et
on force va y aura toujours celsis mais
celle ci s'applique même grandes lans
convaincre mais il le joue immédiatement
je veux revenir en p3 plus tôt -
christian bale 6 et en sarre ça vous
dérange pas mais manger ça ouvre on nous
fout et logiquement ça devrait quand
même bien se passer ici avec la paire de
faux braquage sur le roi alors est-ce
que je reprends la toute fin de match
auront b4 ce que est ce que ça vous le
prouve forcément les change tout ok ah
non
très madame ici va reprendre le pion jeu
mais d'après 6 menaces et des sacrifices
damas est fou b6 on voit vraiment trop
affaibli il donc je devrais pouvoir
conclure assez rapidement simone belle
palais pas au son cavalier à 4 j'ai
pensé arty 26 caracas mais si c'était
contrôle et donc je voyais pas trop
comment poursuivre on suit l'or ça c'est
plutôt bien joué pour fermer mon fou
elle pointe ce qui l'affaiblît quand
même les cases noires ici je vous fous
6,5 braquer des six questions je jouais
damas la table je vais damas sept
équidés un peu bourrin et la pub 10
secondes qu'a modèles d'amd cathy menace
match est très bien joué j'aurais pu ne
pas le voir pour cette c'est pas mater
se vérifier je me décide à ma vie tu
m'as tu l'a pas dit
cheikh cheveux par le match mais après
vous baissiez ce a priori je vois pas de
coups pour lui je vérifie qu'il a pas
pêcher quand même voilà c'est fait sur
la première projet et du coup il est
tombé mais cet homme atteint par abc le
début salut baron tous bonne chance à
toi si tu n'auras pas forcément besoin
ici alors qu'est ce que ça donne d'un
bouquet variés dans le coin c'est pas
forcément terrible je vais faire
confiance
on va jouer symétrique ici je peux pas
jouer f6 et un courage
du coup il veut prendre le centre
d'entrée au caire je me contentais des
six comme 3 yann est ce que ça va dès
qu'on joue au foot pionsat ouvre d aegon
a bêtement inhabituel verte où leur père
voulait vraiment pas à l'abri de faire
une boulette à chaque coup là je vais
quand même
voilà c'est beau quand même c'est pas
comme si je l'avais vu eddy et
l'expliqué la seconde avant mais j'ai un
peu de chance je vais quand même a
priori récupérer le plomb le 4 mai ça
s'annonce brillant quand même sept
heures trente de jeu
je passe les finir au dessus des 2000 la
leur pour hockey sneijder c'est comme
aux échecs clasico avant goût qu'une
pièce entre le roi et la tour et tu dois
toucher ton roi permet vous prendre ce
pion bas
je te vois tu dois toucher ton roi et
l'amener sur la case de ta tour et ça
jouera le coup le roc automatiquement
freine c'est que je perds plein de haine
pour voir où j'en suis et j'aime pas ça
mais je vais quand même le rouge r j'ai
vu que la première partie j'ai joué tous
les coups dans avec un programme ans
s'est très mal passé mais du coup je
suis déjà ben ali si ça lâche 5 cuil le
drame est proche j'ai vraiment failli
donner madame y avoir du cahier c5 ça
m'embête un peu j'ai pas vraiment bonnes
cases pour madame je veux revenir on
c'est déprimant de venir ici ne va pas
mieux
j'aurais pu me prendre un match de
l'idiot aussi alors là est ce que est ce
que fout et six matches où j'avais pas
vu a évidemment g4 j'ai perdu ma taille
joue pas je crois que je m'en sors ah
non mais c'est dramatique ici que
quelqu'un à ses avoirs dans le chat à
peu traité s'il vous plaît je demande un
cerveau tout neuf ça je te passe le lien
rhinos si tu vas tu inscrire au tournoi
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une date queen
queen j'ai pas maintien d'une peau car
ben donc là c'est la perte sèche de la
piasse a priori rien ça va de mal en pis
j'ai aucune tactique
ban à tour madame n'aime pas défendu
j'aurais pu aussi le gratter deux
piastres pour la dame mais non il n'ya
pas de miracles ici
en même temps on ne mérite pas au
miracle ce que j'abandonne et ouais je
vais abandonner essayer de relancer
notre parti et d'oublier ça s'allume pas
oxydée à tort d'être très heureux je
serai autant à ta place
c'est un carnage années d'échecs 960
pour un cerveau à jeun comme ça comme le
bien je ne vois rien
je devais pas d'échec j'avais rien
assurément
j'ai l'impression de voir d'avoir des
visions en fait de voir trouble à chaque
coup je menace de donner quelque chose
je pense juste et je vais très vite et
mal donc de jouer très lentement et mal
à ce que j'allais aussi à moto piégée
moustoir-ac une performance de réussir
interstructures quatre coups et que les
blancs pensent que ce n'était pas facile
mais j'ai réussi à placer mes cavaliers
de sorte à ne pas pouvoir le défendre
c'est assez dangereux de ma part donc
c'est le style tragi-comique ici
non non je perds deux hommes qui ont ces
beaux matchs je joue vite je joue vite
quel est le plus mauvais coolissime lmh
et rapide à 4 va attaquer ce nouvel
objectif est de terminer à la moyenne
dans ce tournoi j'ai quand même j'ai
très très mal à mes cavaliers rare
stupidité les avoirs placés comme sa
classe est fière de moi en fait quelque
part qu'à voyager ça qu'il mourrait juge
ou à la chine et puis j'aurais eu l'air
encore plus bête je ne l'était n'est pas
un mince exploit
je vais essayer de le faire un petit
piège j'ai l'impression que ça a marché
même si je sais pas si mon cavalier il
va ressortir l'idée c'est que la salle
cascante a devancé bessette je pourrai
manger son cavalier après je certaine
qu'on reperde le mien abandonnait donc
il est protégé apparemment fois ci ce
que je n'allais pas furent à la base
fait à chaque coup je découvre quelque
chose dans la position que je fais un
échec ici serait peut-être mon premier
échec du tournoi tu pas sûrs de réussir
en fer doute plus tard je veux d'alger 4
et aux pieds
pour être sacré une caille et sur ces
sept ça se passe mal mais des fois ça
peut être rigolo il peut ressortir je
sais pas il ya du f st car j'ai des
sacrifices eux si ce que fout les cinq à
dix ans je ne sais pas non plus
ty pas jouer vite et j'ai dit que
j'avais juste les mâles mais je n'arrive
pas visiblement pas j'ai joué b4 et je
vois mon objectif c'est de sauver ce
cavalier et la terre f5 certainement ce
qui fait que d'objets 4t pas forcément
si mal
[Musique]
ouais je vais à l'amour à trois ici je
suis allé chez qui la jugent même où et
c'est donc ça n'a rien de cette tare des
singles en fait mais c'est pas possible
pourquoi j'ai pas vu ça non plus ce
n'est pas dramatique malgré tout mais
c'est assez difficile à chaque coup de
ne pas voir le coup de l'adversaire
la souffrance je suis à grosses gouttes
j'ai une pièce de plus le bon j'ai ici
il préfère dame prend il
placé en poupe et ça quand je serai
vraiment extrêmement haut j'ai gagné
pour hachette se dit qu'il doit marcher
ici peut-être ailleurs un fou g7 je ne
suis peut-être pas mettre tous mes
cavaliers faut que je joue des coûts où
je joue découvre que j'arrête de parler
c'est très dur de jeu des coupes
je vais ressortir le cavalier sera
toujours ça de pris
il y aura tout un point mais c'est pas
grave
encore une fois je n'avais pas anticipé
aurait très bien pu perdre la partie là
dessus car si je pouvais m'en fous je me
prends d'amour ans après je n'attaque
pas je fasse attention
oui me lasse pas de me prendre je vais
m'en fermer un deuxième cavaliers salah
rigolo
devrais je vous ai 7 6 6 2
complètement gagnant mais mais vu le
temps vu que je ne vois rien rien n'est
certain
la gamme d'options pour la pièce surtout
j'ai quinze secondes
je vais manger développer je vais
rockets on voit qu'il va faire le grand
écart alors bon je devais d'abord je me
fous ces 3 vient de voir une tactique en
d'un crew attention attention toxines à
tort je commence à voir la tactique en
daim ça va être dur pour toi là comme
infantile a clairement de vue du jeu un
pour la pièce après j'ai du tourin donc
là je pense que je suis gagnant
tactiquement il a pas de casse pour
saddam tv5 je vais jouer cavalier prend
le 5e oui mais aussi la gare album il
faut hélas il a trouvé ce coup quand
même il peut revenir j'avais pas vu peu
son ca partir ballon heureusement
tentant de sacrifier ici mais je
perdrais mon avantage matériel et bien
sûr mangera g7 préparait du tourin ici
je sais pas est-ce qu'il faut prendre
y'aura une fourchette sert prend un sens
aiguisé de la tactique qui porte ses
fruits
je vous appréciez heureusement il a sa
tour en prix ça ne marche pas j'oserais
dire que je l'avais vu peut-être réussi
à remonter à 50% ici
et on a ramené ce fou c'est de manger et
il a montré en septième je fais un petit
coup de bendjé 3 ça mange pas de pain
perdu h4 c3 on va consolider
j'ai une tour de plus ici normalement
une tour de plus et bien normalement ça
se passe bien mais j'arrive pas à mettre
dans des pièges tout seul par le maître
du couloir
ça c'est vraiment indispensable et
derrière va porter le coup de grâce au
joueur allemand a même mangé tous ses
pions bassement ont eu 10 ans abandonne
espères-tu ce genre de choses d'accord
on va tout jouer f3 ça aurait été
intelligent mais j'arrive à besoin
d'extraire sont rois je suis assez
serein le match je regarde plus la
pendule
j'ai de faire d'arma ii ici imparable
c'est une victoire et dont j'ai alors
ici je rejoue contre bar où décidément
pas vous fier de prendre ma revanche ne
pas te donner de cassan d'un coup cette
fois at il du coup je ne suis pas là du
tout ce qui se passe je pars que ça se
passe mieux pour vous pour moi priori ça
peut difficilement moins bien se passer
[Musique]
c'est de pas maté de même pas m'attaquer
depuis on a un coût de plus et pas de
piège pas de choses mesquine
je suis à peu près certain de rater une
pio et défendu depuis avoir un joli
match typique je dis ça c'est de partir
pour la menaçant d'un la dame qui va
même bien mal placé en bien je vais
reprendre comme ça mais je vais me
reprendre encore dérives des thèmes
tactique c'est terrible cette série un
petit fou g46 de derrière les fagots
forcé roy c7
il parle beaucoup on a vraiment envie de
jouer a priori rien avec les noirs là et
pas vu moi aussi j'ai le droit de
planter des tactiques
je voudrais bien qu'elle et ses seins
qu'on a c'est qu'il ya eu 6 et là bas
tout en l'air on va exister je vais
jouer f5 chez part j'ai pas si m5 et si
bien que j'aie 3l ceinture à calais il y
avait celle des cadres j'ai trois
valeurs plus solide en grâce à ce sujet
80 km par ahm ce que je l'étais auquel
sa a désorganisé pièce schéma bien
activé madame maintenant
c'est assez logique ici et je vais je me
fous à 3 pour défendre parce que le
cahier prouver sa carrière j'ai 3 était
peut-être moins bon que f5 au final je
suis embêté avec ce courage en fait dans
la colonne ff5 et province un plan très
très désagréable je me fais que jouer
partout
pas de moyens de défendre je ne vois pas
de moyens de défendre je vous prends des
3 et puis on prend ici le concept plutôt
bien mais pas de solution a toutefois
choc terrible
non ça marche pas j'ai pas de coup j'ai
pas de coups encore une fois je joue et
ça c'est de créer des tactiques à un
fonds de variantes avec du fou les cinq
meilleurs c'est pas convaincant c'est
pas convaincant
bouger comme les deux fous sont rois
dans les profondeurs c'est pas clair a
créé après je suis assez déçu malgré
tout aille prendre la tour ok j'ai pas
dû peut s'initier au jeu laisse sortir
cette pièce j'ai encore été extrêmement
rapide
si ce que je dirai que du matériel non
lesquels chelsea qui tient tout d'un peu
de chance nature gfr d'hab c'est le
surnom joué que six lui-même mais je
suis pas un mais deux derrière bon va
faire la pub de derrière c'est ce qu'est
la fourchette adha dans l'idée de la
voir ou juste roquet a montré très dur
de je me vide en parlant pour moi le
lenteur extrême on vous proposait fouet
f2 mais je pense qu'il ya aucun coût qui
résolvait vraiment mes problèmes mais ça
arrive de jouer ces cinq ok je vais
manquer à ses le grand que je pensais
que c'était oui nous tirons que matt
ours français j'étais assez bon
la mauvaise nouvelle non sur ses 5 est
ce que je peut sacrifier
oui mais du coup il l'a vu il faut que
je joue plus vite ta meuf deux cavaliers
des arts déranger si j'aurais dit m
cette défend tous des ventes ou et
l'attaquant plus on va jouer ici du coup
je suis très déçu je suis très déçu de
rater quelque chose sur son roi je
n'aime pas perdre autant
ce qu'imaginent lecavalier des six mais
je vais manger hachette a priori initial
je lutte comme celui de lille c'est
difficile je vous écoute je prévois
parle ça me fait perdre beaucoup de
temps bien joué de sa part
non je ne sais pas la ferme dame f4 et
j'ai pas content des changes des dames
ont clairement pas qu'est-ce que je joue
pas bien c'est terrible parce que je
pense que j'ai déjà fait quand même de
très bonne compensation
oh là là c'est pas possible
non c'est un carnage je vais
certainement avoir quelque chose sur soi
ici un priori abandonné star continuer
le massacre en dit
non je m'y attendais ce tout je suis pas
déçu je savais que météo tout aux
piégeurs en jouant aux échecs 900 sur la
scène au réveil trop d'informations pour
mon cerveau juste là autant échec
classique on peut se reposer un petit
peu sur sur nos schémas habituels mais
là il ya trop de bouleversements et les
juges - aucune tactique en un coup j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un brouillard
devant les yeux très difficile j'ai rien
trop peut-être que c'est pas c'est bien
parce que maintenant il veut en faire
bafouer m'attaque l'attaquent ici
la bonne nouvelle pourrait ne pas en
être une je veux kg 5
mais on va avoir une mais deux sont très
fragiles au centre joue un petit peu
avec le feu
là en fait c'est ça le secret à jeff je
vise les 960 lots anboto attribué à la
mode mondialement très mal
[Musique]
pendant que les minos qui réfléchit
petit peu je vais regarder le classement
et du coup cette nuit là est d'un
bourreau de la première ronde qui rasent
barbarian et là aussi je suis au fin
fond il reste une petite heure pour
essayer quand même de se refaire
d'enchaîner deux victoires sera un bel
exploit
j'ai envie de jouer f3 ici l'eau risque
fou aussi c'est fort j'y passe jusqu'à
trois bons coups il veut vraiment
solidifier cette structure et du foie
schisme il ya beaucoup de richesses de
ressources complètement inhabituelle
juste là il n'est pas tué du coup à
gérer tout ça il faut pas m'en être
affûté avoir le cerveau frais et dispos
ce qui vous l'aurez compris n'est pas
mon cas c'est dans cette partie ça se
passe plutôt bien j'ai en plus j'ai la
paire dufour je vais rockets jeu
h4 ouais mais son fois çi ce serait bien
de trouver un moyen de faire quelque
chose avec cette avec cette dame où je
vais jouer tour bergues sais pas où je
vais jouer à quatre afin de prendre un
peu d espace ici sur mon jouet a surpris
même voilà c'est fait je vais sortir
madame je sais tout prend des six la
marche pas tout à fait pour l'instant
point de vous remettre un cavalier
devant même l'air prometteur et
dangereux j'ai eu 5 1 bien sûr ici la
position normale écrasante mais daisy
bascule bonjour tous fatigués
du coup donne sa tour sur échec je vais
la prendre je peux prendre ça aussi et
je vais remercier de sa générosité minos
l'e-book plus gentil que certains
affaires adversaire pardon tout va
tomber autour du roi là c'est un peu la
cata je remonte à 50% suspense où
l'objectif final la moyenne bourget au
17 fait longtemps qu'une partie ce
n'était pas aussi bien passée un âge où
sa voix très heureux beaucoup de
matériel en plus cela devrait bien se
passer même réussi à forcer la bande ou
préserve me fous qui plus est pour un
cavalier et trois pions et minos les
minos mais je comprends il m'a vu jouer
donc il dit on sait jamais l'accident
est encore possible et je parle de fer
petit nom du coup j'aurais bien aimé
trouver un match mais elle fait pas si
facile ici pas si facile
j'ai pas de bons coups dans cette
position frustrant je bouge moins fous
ils mangent sur el cheikh
je pars en canon fait un petit rend pas
très grave nous perdra jusqu'à
patricienne attention si je bouge le fou
il ya des réseaux perpète
je suis capable de balise est parti sous
la mousse tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que je ne devrais pas réfléchir
pourtant
que je fais j'ai envie de donner ce pont
j'ai envie de donner ce qui me gêne plus
qu'autre chose d'actifs de mes pièces
se faire un joli match faire un truc
bien sa dépense qui joue un pur instant
je me lasse pas vraiment mais j'ai
décidé alors là je pense que tout
raciste je vais réussir à battre et
c'est la victoire alors j'ai tout ravi
du cavalier à cette jeune dame csn
callas est des plus jolies je remonte à
50%
j'affronte digigram grob bonne chance dj
hell faut que je revienne peut-être ma
1ere 2e victoire d'affilée je veux dire
si je vais vite à merci merci dj il est
tombé dans le piège et si cette équipe
est de gagner la dame
ça a fonctionné très malin est une
victoire aux deux coups assez beau
désolé de dire ça c'est typiquement
basque il m'arrive depuis le début de
toute façon diagonale imprévus et c'est
l'accident
[Musique]
toujours en bas tu y vas t'il j'aurais
pu me le prendre clairement je suis
obligé écarquiller les yeux en grand
pour éviter ce genre de mésaventure avec
une dame de plus je vous invite à voir
ici peut menacer maths quand même à bata
l'étouffer ça serait presque pour
quelque part je me le prenne
mais
mais quand même je suis désolé ou pour
jouer en sus pour être délaissées mais
j'ai encore espoir de rattraper un petit
peu alors qui a fait de toi je change
tout j'ai une dame de plus je vais
vraiment pas faire dans la finesse ici
pour ma visite j'ai de la chance par
cavalier qui obstruent j'évite le drame
qui plonge et 5 alors les changes plus
beaux anges - chirurgie 5,6 nous laisse
faire
le coupe d'arbres cavaliers y ait assez
de prometteur longère c'est de gagner
assez vite pour monter un petit peu je
ramène une tour maintenant je ne passais
pas réussi aurait balancé le pion à
chaud cyril va jouer tour g3 je vais
d'abord 5
deuxième d'hab ça ira plus vite
je crains pas grand chose je peux
crémone c'est le baht désole t-il gir
pour pour la part la non partie avec
cette dame de morts août 2 coûte
j'affronte julien roux à julien qui est
un très bon joueur et autant dire que ça
s'annonce compliqué ici et je vais
essayer de faire mieux je pense que le
mieux pour moi serait de retrouver une
position qui ressemble à quelque chose
de le plus normal qu'ils aient pas trop
tactique le cerveau puisse supporter ces
supplices j'attaque un pion sortir nous
fout et vingrau banques
je me 3 c'est de jouer de manière très
très terre à terre que ça se passera
mieux peut-être pas un chameau ils
peuvent attaquer si je fais grands alors
pour
j'y viens autant d'allemands rare que ça
mérite d'être signalé salut bouddha
merci à la beuverie jeunes auraient bien
besoin
toute la force que tu peux me donnait
alors fouillé cannes dont je le ferme 3
ici je pense qu'il va reculer pour y
manger ok ok ok avec quoi je reprends
les deux prisons du sens je prends comme
ça pour ouvrir à tous l égard d une
protection pour le piment
je vais faire à craon revanche j'ai joué
le 4
sûrement je vais
6 1 mais en fait cette diagonale ça
c'est assez gênant pour lui les petites
haines c'est pas si facile de mettre son
roi abri des fois j'ai du cavalier à 4
et 7 5 avec le 4e n'est ce pas grand
show de ryan alors il va jamais mangé
toute façon on va voir si j'ouvre en
compte les jours en cas d'arrêt sans
j'ai pas très envie de voler cinq sa
ferme rêve fou jouer damage de ici
d'ailleurs peut-être un match de fou
d'amour était ont été très forts ils
n'auraient pas pu défendre son cavalier
avec sa tour j'ai dû rater ça je pense
la bâche de sa posé pas mal de problèmes
il aurait eu du mal à rockets alors il
va sûrement jouer cavalier left banke
ali est le 6ème fourchette qui
épaississent peut-être voilà assez
dommage que j'aie raté ceux d'amazon
ce que à 4 donne quelque 4 j'ai envie de
créer des trucs verts sont rois ah si
facile à mettre en place mais chut je
perds moins de faire fonctionner des
choses auxquelles je joue à 5
du coup il affaiblit encore un peu plus
les 15 - comment je peux faire ici
puisqu'il ya peu une idée brillante
je vois pas je mets b3 toujours utile en
cette case pour ce cavalier pour ce qui
s'y fait pas même bien mais c'est
difficile vous trouvez maintenant
comment comment casser tout ça peut-être
nous faut valero h3 créer des menaces
avec les deux faux braquer sur la grande
diagonale courage troy corser a menacé
des fois je vais sur ce courage pour
l'instant tout éléphants du vin tout
seul pour lui ça tient vraiment à un
film et tout d'un coup je trouve des
moyens doit de rajouter de la pression
fou et c'est peut-être pour mettre
saddam ou rachètent où elle sera moins
bien placé alors si je prends des 5
c'est vraiment intéressant c'est un tour
des trois ici liquide est prenant dessin
avec le derrière d'avoir deux tours c3
c'est un peu chaud pour son roi malgré
tout
alors j'ai 5 janvier d'ignorer je vais
manger et je vais vraiment ged
mais finalement est-ce que je veux
quelque chose je suis pas certain donc
c3 c4 mon idée mais j'arrive pas à
l'échelon que j'avais papa du tour à
17,7 dangereux j'ai pas pensé à ça je
n'ai pas pensé à ça plongez en dessin
que le c'est risquer tout va toujours un
peu trop de cases va se décliner après
vraiment de faire passer ça marche
ouais ça j'avais pensé je m'étais dit
que je sacrifierais des trucs et que ça
se passerait de l'ain le sacrifier des
trucs et ça se passera par cette
possible ce qui effectivement sur oissel
je vois pas trop comment profiter
finalement
[Musique]
je suis assez déçu c'est pas clair il va
mieux mais ça et j'ai joué à agen qui
s'y regroupent germain t&c d'hab on sait
pas où elle va ça de la tête un f6 quand
même car n'est ce pas possible j'ai
encore pas de dames g7 quoi bon et du
coup je suis officiellement map
je pense que tu es plutôt très bien
certainement gagnant mais j'ai dû rater
des choses joratel des choses
c'est pas foutu un affectueux mais vu la
position que j'avais c'est quand même
très dommageable j'ai pas réussi à
trouvé la tactique qui marchait je ne
prends que j'écarte dans le monde
donnait alors sur gk joseph 4 toute
façon elle va fermer
il a joué tour des simples que c'était
stupide à ce que j'ai fait voilà
complètement stupide parce que changer
c'est extrêmement balle jouer plaît
c'est manque un temps je vous laisse il
avait rien que mon roi ici mais il
manque un temps donc ça va juste perdre
sa juste perdre et puis dans un peu
logique nouvelle fois j'ai fait
n'importe quoi partir d'une position qui
était certainement complètement gagnante
j'arrive pas à faire des trucs c'est
juste assez ridicule chez aucun moyen de
chatouiller ses pions 8 doivent faire
fou des cinq humeurs et juste tataryn
dames c'est très facile
sipa troupes et à mener pour en abaisser
la prestance n'a aucun sens alors que
ouais j'avais plutôt bien jouer cette
partie m jusqu'au moment de porter le
coup de grâce
la portanelle retourner dans ma spirale
de défaites
[Musique]
ouais j'ai pas trouvé d'autre chose que
d'amener la toile mais c'est sûr que je
regardais après mais je suis sûr que je
vais être foutu amont et y avait trop de
clouage mais vous était très bien placé
mais la touche tactique n'est vraiment
pas au rendez vous aujourd'hui c'est
très difficile bonjour peu barbare hier
n'ont plus autant de dire c'est pas un
cadeau c'est un peu plus des taux
réduits au moins toute façon vu que je
suis dans le brouillard sert à rien de
c'est de bien jouer je fais des coûts de
pions qui ont des bilans encore une fois
mon jean ces trois hommes s'étaient
d'abord selon libé je vais c4 un peu
cavalier là je me sens que je vais faire
mon fou mais bon est-ce grave je vais
quand même un peu fixé son ton ici donc
c'est plutôt une réussite pour moi mais
pas forcément décisif non plus vous
pouvez vous mettre mes cavaliers
l'alliance est là peut-être joué t3
simplement bonnaire j'aurai une
meilleure structure qui si objectivement
je dois être un peu mieux du fait de
démissions isoler j'aurais bien aimé
planté un petit truc il y en a pas je
6les c'est changer s'ils veulent changer
ces risques là pour moi de garder les
dames sur l'échiquier
maintenant je veux bien prendre absolue
je le tour des huit
je vais relire mes tours il fait grand
auquel il a raison beaucoup des six
c'est d'activer ce fou j'avais du cahier
7,4 intérêts du sens maintenant je vais
plus évidemment sur l'a5 vers un fou et
3 x 3 qui va certainement et mais quoi
qu'il arrive
du coup ici je suis un peu embêté malgré
tout donc la défense de ce pion un petit
peu de bach et qu'elle va alléger si
c'est pas terrible je vais h4
ouais tu vois la défendre ce qu'ils ont
fait pour être joué à six voix
tranquille ce que j'irais pas mettre en
relief 4 celui des agrafes de se faire
doubler lyon j'espère j'espère que c'est
pas là je vous dis que j'aurais même la
perte de folie si objectivement 4 qui
sera ouvert moi je doit permettre bien
mais on a réussi en jusqu'au bout à ne
pas faire n'importe quoi autant dire que
c'est une mission compliquée j'ai gagné
des trois qui est problème 2 je vais le
jouer
j'ai le perpétuel je ne vais pas le
point je vais essayer de gagner cette
partie mais cela tour du coup il ya vous
prend 1,4
mongin cavaliers peut-être va-t-il me
respectent et abandonnait merci
barbarian enfin une partie à peu près
propre de ma part si swiss pour ça que
je n'ai pas joué y avait quand même des
contreparties c'est la manche numéro 3
notre baron fou qui ma bête noire
aujourd'hui bon jusque sous les doigts
par contre contrairement aux fourneaux
dont peut-être pas moins deux fois mais
elle
alors g20 de doubler les noirs je peux
vous avez remarqué mais j'ai beaucoup
plus souvent les noirs que les blancs a
pour l'instant calimero toujours par les
statistiques à la fin mai et quand même
et chez le sortir mes pièces de rester
sur une bonne dynamique
bon sinon peut-être deux parties correct
ils m'attaquent il a compris que
j'allais matin qu'il a fallu enlever il
a bien raison
ça fait vraiment du sens de la position
bon je vais le laisser pousser son pion
en lui disant c'est pas grave asile à
ben l'histoire je suis de sortir mes
pièces prendre les cases est stoppé par
un fou la question c'est est ce que je
vois schiste ou pas a priori pour
l'instant on va dire ou pas je préfère
plutôt regarder la possibilité je vais
g6 pas lui permettent d'installer un
cavalier au f5 sur le long terme
[Musique]
avez vous été capté pour l'instant
décale je contrôle
je vois bien un petit coup j'ai cinq
jeux pas pourquoi on instinct me dit le
maître mot forgé 5 je l'écoutais n'a
rarement fait défaut depuis le début de
ce tournoi
comment ne pas lui faire confiance à
chaque foulée 5 c'est le nom ce qui va
se passer
handicap
ouais alors fou et 3 wave 3 où il veut
juste sortir cette pièce j'imagine je
vais cavalerie avec 4 je vois des trous
ces demies engouffrer il protège tout je
vais jouer à 5
parce que j'ai envie de jouer à saint
jacques et du coup ça il peut jouer les
4 ici le mot j'ai pas des trucs là j'ai
pas des trucs ça mériterait que j'ai des
trucs pas ce que vous en pensez mais moi
je trouve que je mériterai d'avoir des
trucs bien souvent d'avoir des trucs on
l'aidera pas au final je crois
mais ce qu'il fait mais bon ça a l'air
d'aller un peu boiteuse manque ya laissé
tout faire mais ça lui fait plaisir
ces erreurs devraient manger la position
on s'enrichit pas précéderont ok je vois
un trou je pénètre fabs de fabrice la
devise de rocco ici tu ci-dessus rocco
en direct c'est beau les références
qu'on mérite aujourd'hui tient à si je
vous suis pas quoi faire je sens qu'il
ya des trucs mais j'ai du mal à les
faire fonctionner j'ai envie de voir les
policiers va pas être pleutres je sais
pas il ya des cases des trucs de
diagonale
il s'en fout royalement de tout ce que
je fais ok je vais pas de manger ce fou
a priori je suis quand même content de
mon geste fou et baden pourrait être tel
sac stephen c 6 6 6 7 6 ouais on va voir
comment il défend son pion doit être
bien ici un lieu encore une fois on a pu
voir que c'était pas en sa mort sonne
une victoire dame sait si ça sert à rien
je vais me sa part une pièce sauter la
partie en fait j'aimerais bien filtrer
impeccable 6 plus logique pour mettre la
pression sur une b3 jeu dams et 4 du
coût sera pas une grande réussite c'est
coutelle j'aurai des 5
est ce que ces cinq ici en bons coups je
sais pas j'ai envie d'ouvrir mon fou ça
paraît normal s'agit évidemment pas
d'une enfilade en un coup
pas trop m'en demandait hockey balle
attachement à tolérer
dommage je ne m'avoue pas vaincu mais
quand même il stable clairement mais
peut dire iluv jesse j'ai encore du jeu
j'ai deux fous mais a priori c'est
plutôt moi qui faisait planter une
tactique de la position mais bon le
cerveau a décidé autrement
je vais finir par faire petit roi
quelques jours j'ai deux fois de plus
cette fois j'étais peines sont dans les
grands à godard
au 17 a priori c'est pas dramatique
les rockets il va peut-être rendre le
matérialisme non justement manger
d'autres mais peut-être gourmands j'ai
tendance à vouloir sacrifier mes pions
peut-être trop 1.96 m'embête limite plus
je vais je pars ok vas faire ton
problème 6 c'est bien joué et joue bien
comme un baron officiel 34
j'aurais dû jouer à tempo six manches
c'est pas grave j'aurais dû dams et 7
oui j'ai pas vu pourquoi je vous le
demande pourquoi dites le moi envoyez
moi un message entre qui n'est pas
possible et perd tout mais parti comme
ça dans des fourchettes des clouage des
choses ont fait in dans ce qu'on va
finir en beauté secrétariat à bagram
aoufous au moins
moi j'aurais tête à jour en elle du coup
le torrent
veut plus de relance et de partie liée à
ses propos il me comprend après 13
heures c'est un horaire difficile c'est
pour ça darren de 13h essayé de faire
des choses à demont plus décent et
j'affronte alex vers stade j'ai pas où
j'en suis je la moyenne ou pas va être
plus à quelque chose comme ça ah si mal
il me fait un piège entre essaie de
jouer sur b3 et jacques bourdin coup ça
aurait pu marcher mes joueurs français
ne s'est jamais relevé ici la pièce
c'est à dire que je fais le tour de
france à pied mais ses adversaires sont
en vélo autant dire que j'en suis à la
première étape quand ils en sont venus à
l'alpe d'huez c'est difficile je regarde
le classement me vois pas mettre trop
loin ou d'aïn el khir hasard août sur 12
baron fou qui est bien aussi
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe lg c'est
gagner une partie de d'éviter pari fou
la remontée derrière est 25 minutes à la
difficile à faire gagner des parties du
temps j'arriverai
à l'objectif de 961 malheureusement pas
un peu un peu compliqué ouh là là la
petite feinte le faux premo j'ai cru que
j'étais défendu et non c'est un gambit
c'est voulu je vous relire mon adresse
bagarre danse plonge le récupère
facilement mais c'est un bon indicateur
niveau des blancs très j'adorerais
pouvoir faire des blagues marcquois
j'adorerais ou attention et m de
cloisons souvent été fatal et je vais
jouer que six pour le beau jeu peut-être
faire des trucs sympas avec 1.6
s'ils veulent jouer f5 ici je pense
qu'il aurait intérêt parce que sinon il
y aura du mal à faire jouer ses pièces
de l'ale d'hab
j'ai pas trop ça c'est encore la dame
maintenant c'est encore des notions
d'amitié à y avoir bien il veut s'en
prendre à mouscron
je suis un peu sceptique malgré tout sur
ce coup un petit peu passif
j'essaie de faire une grosse chaîne la
chaîne a d'adoption sur carte blanche
ici ou là j'ai eu peur du trailer d'une
seconde d'un flash is matt
or que mille solutions mais aller
je ferme auxquels je parle grand succès
le grand je vais pas ok m cailleux 3 ici
j'attaque des 5 c'est pas là le rock
oui mais voilà maintenant je menace
l'europe d'ailleurs nos adversaires ont
fait de même s'il est quand même assez
heureux de son fourrage suite ici alex
puisque pouvoir recycler et je vais
jouer b3 on mourir le mien je vais juste
comprendre ces 5 1 qui gagne la partie
on a un coût mais je suis pas comme ça
l'élu j'étais quelqu'un de généreux et
altruiste envers mes semblables
après deux fois de suite c'est trop un
cadeau ça va 2 ça devient une habitude
le fait échec mais c'était prévu pour on
a trouvé un petit abri là je regardais
madame ici c'est très beau très fort il
sacrifier une qualité
pourquoi pas mais ça se passe bien et
c'est pas souvent que ça arrive il faut
le dire
adam effectivement b5 ici alors quand
même assez menaçante là du tout reprend
ses six cavaliers mais sa carrière est
ce que qu'a eu cinq marches qui a aidé
catherine simplement un problème c'est
qu'il joue avec avec trois pièces deux
mois quelque part me permets de le
battre elle c'est le début de la
remontée des reste 20 minutes voient
toujours pas
ouais cggc un grand boum aller aux
toiles merci merci beaucoup d'âme au
quai antoine antoine antoine ça donne
quoi cette position-là nos fous comme ça
ok c'est tout bizarre et regardez bien
mesquin la bonne ascendant au premier
coup assez fort chez classique on
n'arrive pas à faire des blagues aussi
portes dès le premier coup nas presque
d'oublier la partie c'est quelque part
elle serait assez beau il l'a vu le jour
en france et qu'il l'a vu du coup il a
sûrement de faire la même chose a
largement anticipée et là il pourrait
menacer bat presque je fasse attention
le ciel bien c'était charmant très mal
joué mais si ça je me faire un groupe ou
sur carte blanche et je vais avoir du
mal à le algériens c'était fou 2 je suis
pas très malin donc jouée ces six ans
resté très bon allez je peux anticiper
du coup je louche et 6 encaissés 7
si je vois un peu vite pour marquer des
points ah oui j'ai besoin de tout le
support là aidez moi je donne tout c'est
la 5
pour le joueur français la grosse
fringale
j'avais bien rock et de ce côté là j'ai
deux trois pièces à déblayer vous la
corde mais voir attaquer avec mes pions
mais ça se fait j'ai ma dose pour jouer
des simples potentiel goût pour
l'instant ne contrôle pas celle à gaz je
jouais qu'avait lieu six menace rien
le nasria j'ai pas peur de l'affirmer ne
menace rien je veux sortir m'en fous il
menace
chose attention je me la suis pris à sa
part dans deux fois sa fourchette à je
peux essayer de faire ça alex persane je
vais encore perdre 400 points l'eau mais
c'est pas là alors il se pète et pour
celui connaissent pas cet european poker
tour
c'est un petit peu l'équipe alors on va
dire de des masters series au tennis
parce que les plus gros tournois en tout
cas d'europe et je n'ai pas fait 36 à la
première expérience était à prague
c'est à moi de jouer je vais peut-être
que foulée fluide pour garder le fou rac
c'était mon colocataire qui avait gagné
a inscrit deux shows passer des
inscriptions à l'époque 7 10 mille
dollars l'entrée au tournoi est à peu
près 500 joueurs et donc là les prix
sont évidemment colossaux du coup et moi
je faisais tous les side event à côté
après mon expérience a trahi a été
compliqué parce qu'on était logé dans un
hôtel cinq étoiles au hilton sq ont été
invités à tout ça non sur cette compris
dans le package n'a lui aucun frais
sauf que vous j'avais vingt ans que tu
as forcément le compte en banque que
très fort nine plus et puis sur l'été
jeunes n'est pas trop préparé notre
voyage est ce qui fait que au bout de
deux trois soirs là c'est compliqué de
pouvoir en fait se payer à manger qui
fait qu'on allait au bac d'eau ramener
le bac d'eau à l'hôtel cinq étoiles des
terrains petit peu les seuls jusqu'à
l'hôtel a priori vous allez commencer
par éviter le mini bar le premier jour
en pensant que c'était pas offert vous
que du coup la note était de quelque
chose que
on me mille 1000 euros étant donné que
la bouteille d'eau en plastique août et
10 euros
c'est assez compliqué ensuite de revenir
après ça je ne pouvais même plus payer
le métro non plus j'étais parti en
courant d'ailleurs à ce moment là après
un contrôle de deux flics rouge où s à
enghien c'était vraiment la caricature
les mecs tu savais qu'ils allaient
pouvoir l'amour d'après elle est
certainement pas déclarés donc moi
j'étais parti en courant mais mon pote
était resté donné sa carte d'identité
donc j'avais dû revenir là j'ai pas
compris la part manger 20e mais je lui
en suis gré et donc j'avais dû revenir
un peu déçu du coup vous avez été gentil
avait réussi à négocier leur donner
quelques euros une nouvelle à laisser
partir
c'était un beau séjour pokéristique mans
parlant c'était très mal passé alors il
refait une fourchette je vais gb cinq
piscines mais c'était pas une expérience
sympa et après ensuite j'ai fait le
repère de monte carlo
c'était le là c'est moi qui me suis
qualifié et c'est et je fasse attention
fourchette le manche est ce qu'elles
valent il est beaucoup trop dangereux là
c'était la grande finale c'est un énorme
package à 20000 euros
c'était juste un petit peu le rêve quoi
rêve qui se réalise avec gelé des
millions d'euros vainqueur doit lui qui
est très généreux malheureusement pour
moi j'ai perdu à la fin du t1 je me suis
pris un gros magot petite impro un mec
des sponsorisé par full tilt poker un
peu une caricature du joueur très
agressif mais qui jouait pas très bien
en finir et qui était assez facile à
lire et à vous plaît
et j'ai fini par le faire tilter il
avait fini par me par me payer mon tapis
en gros avec avec change tout avec
hauteur as il avait fait honneur au
bonheur j'avais été assez fâché et donc
ainsi s'était achevé mon expérience en
sorte de péter et bon c'est le genre de
tournois ou pour avoir un fortement la
réussite avec soin sur une semaine et ça
peut changer votre vie est là pour le
coup malheureusement pas d'ailleurs ça
ne s'est pas passé comme ça mais c'était
quand même très sympa reste là pour le
coup j'ai fait plein de side event à
côté et qui sont très bien passées le
niveau était pas par où je trouvais et à
beaucoup de gens très riches qui
viennent l'atmosphère est particulière
ou gens très riches qui viennent et
qu'ils foutent complètement leur argent
il faut un peu n'importe quoi
ouais c'est pas très sain pour vous dire
après
par exemple notable ou jouer en dehors
du tournoi principal
elle est pas mal de filles russes type
mannequin qui venaient le voir et qui
regardait nos mains à voir si on avait
des des alliances c'était un petit peu
ce genre d'atmosphère pour vous donner
un ordre d'idée ce qui est de d'ouvrir
ici prend passant à près de faire le
grand roque j'ai pas joué contre
milliards et non rabattables le mec le
produit n'est pas encore connue je ne
vais pas son nom d'ailleurs mais c'est
ça plus gros bien vu le petit pré bon eh
ouais j'ai pas mal de tics de langage
pokéristique un speed coaching d'avant
le tilt alors appris la danse et c'est
beaucoup
exporter dans le milieu des échecs
c'était le pt monte carlo mais sa date à
l'époque vraiment chez foucault caf
shalit à toulouse 6 à 10 ans celle event
principal le sarm 55 et à prague
juste le pt de près alors jamais
enfin qu on met pièces y sont pas grands
ensembles se fout je vais galérer en
faire quelque chose je pense couverture
s'est pas très bien passé pour moi
contrairement à une adversaire qui a
tant dans la diagonale ouverte
après c'est pas dramatique non plus de
le faire mais aussi se met une partie
peut-être un peu l'anti s'ils n'arrivent
pas vraiment vu la situation du tournoi
c'est de voir vos questions a du coup je
me rappelle même plus de maps de ma
place le sam 55
étant donné que j'ai perdu à la toute
fin de mandat il ya plein de deuil le
coup en fait vous souvient très bien je
vais me faire un peu abîmé ma structure
séparée pourra dire que c'est pas grave
en gros le mec était hyper agressive
était juste à ma côte jusqu'à
l'aboutissement sur moi mais il le fait
en permanence ce qui fait que moi je
passais mon temps à lui revenir dessus
et il se couchait permanente du coup il
était en tilt sous le dominer
complètement mais est arrivé là tu avec
un très gros tapis on était à peu près
équivalent et finalement on était parti
dans une bataille un peu d'ego préflop
moi j'avais le père de 10 ses rêves qui
réalise 3 bet 4 bet etc
et puis et puis c'était venu un flop
hauteur 9 h je parle pour ce qui laisse
un peu le pot car et du coup il va pas
cru donc on est parti à tapis horde pas
c'était un peu chaud de ma part de
partir à tapis mais c'était vraiment
lire l'historique le t4 dip
j'aurais pu jouer de manière plus
conservatrice
il avait juste un square du moteur à
goutrens il a fêté en droit il verra ça
lors une seule carte aurait suffi non
mais c'était quand même assez sale de
jouer sur un tournoi avec un 3 sur un
flop 9 daf 8 6 il était assez heureux du
coup il dépassé magath chipleader de la
table
à l'inversé si j'avais gagné comme cela
aurait dû arriver
j'aurais été bien pour la suite mais bon
c'est comme ça
genre de tora toute façon bien je
voulais loin d'être suffisant pour
gagner
parfois c'est le plus gros fish qui a
récompensé j'ai objectivement a pris
pris la précision est revu les mains
mais même si on rajoute parce qu'on n'a
pas l'occasion de participer à de tels
événements très souvent c est parce qu
un jeu sympa tensions avec mon roi
j'irais bien échanger les dames ici que
madame elle fait vraiment rien montré
sur la colonne jay johanson finale il
veut pas bien sûr
france avoue joue sur le long terme et
c'est clair après détourna comme ça
c'est du court terme parce que à
l'inscription est beaucoup trop cher
pour la payer cash et donc faut se
qualifier réussir à se qualifier c'est
un peu le parcours du combattant il ya
des budgets de joueurs dans les
satellites mais il ya plusieurs
satellites d'affilée c'est compliqué à
part si tu as un budget illimité là tu
peux te permettre mais c'est chaud
on arrive à faire le grand rang serait
bien en fait que moi je ne bougeais un
petit peu aussi
je vais faire pareil va pas la partie la
plus animée si je vais l'annoncer que
c'était fermé ça va être un peu lent
comme parti je pense que j'ai quand même
une meilleure structure et pour
l'instant je contrôle la colonne j'ai
même si normalement il peut la reprendre
j'ai pas vu et c3 tenera j'aurais dû
faire cailler des deux très embêtant ça
je perds lampions gdam f1 mais je
perdais tempo c'est moche
vaches u 19 secondes save est sauvé je
déprime un peu toute la partie
excavation ces trois dames g5 que je
perdais le pew ces quatre et je suis pas
sûr de vouloir faire ça en fait
alors je me revois ces deux ou en trois
sets et de la colonie peut pas vraiment
l'exploiter et bertrand edel chez de
solidifier tout ça c'est laborieux on va
fermer par sestak et se concentrait sur
la colonne jane j'ai pas vu encore
décidé mais je vois pas grand chose
j'aurais dû jouer à trois très logique
la machette et complètement stupide il
accélère la cadence
il veut pas perdre votre temps je suis
content d'avoir la cascade 6 voici c'est
la kabylie qui contrôle auquel on
l'oublié mais ce serait un échange c'est
pas exceptionnel
madame était très bien en f1 je peux
faire un truc à base de foie si si si
pas convaincu
ouais si ça même pas leurs chevaux
oui j'avais prévu de faire ça à gagner
tu matériel et ça devrait bien se passer
je vais chercher son pion le pas me
casser la tête
on peut le seul danger dans la position
exacte - c'est sa femme de fabrice les
satellites changer les dames la banque
donne hélas cinq minutes est essayé de
gagner une dernière partie entre
camonais verra t'il jouer vite pour
finir sur une bonne note
après de nombreux déboires dans cette
arène pour moi comme champ mais pièce je
ne sais pas
là on est les classements la lan qui est
toujours en tête devant bart info poopy
poupe
moi je le vois pas parce qu'on tue pas
pourquoi c'est un bug pas quand même
être quelque part c'est un gambit dhabi
si cameron est là et j'accepte le
candidat parallèle ya pas de maths
bon j'ai vu c'est rigolo gambie dans
notre position je vais essayer de
défendre le pion l'accrochage de petits
plombs il prend au centre il a raison je
vais ça moment je ne sais pas j'ai joué
à six pour essayer de faire passer nous
font part à cet être est malin la petite
fouine et h 30 lieu de 40 faut que je
joue vite si je veux c'est d'arriver au
bout de cette partie merci pas banal et
en cash ça m'a plu meilleure époque je
suis allée comme à d'assez grosses
limites où je jouais en nl1000 sur
everest poker
c'est un bon un bon tremplin
j'ai pas joué extrêmement longtemps et
2000 mais près d'une demi année pour
bien passé puis c'est devenu plus
difficile
pas de granby bah je vais prendre cette
balle à 6 10 heures était un petit peu
le meilleur moyen de boucler ce tournoi
à me prendre une autre fourchette 1 les
sets ça a été la spéciale j'ai pu la
prendre deux ou trois fois déjà
[Musique]
je termine la décrire cros l'a
maintenant faut voir avec les éditeurs
c'étaient les belles âmes est exactement
le sam
si tu joues étoiles aussi beaucoup
peut-être mais le poker était les années
dorées du pot car il ya une dizaine
d'années maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
dur dont faisait 20 sur tout en habitant
en france
à la limite les pros la plupart sont
partis à l'étranger en thaïlande des
choses comme ça joue beaucoup sur
internet le coût de la vie est moindre
et ils peuvent jouer avec le point comme
avec les gens du monde entier
alors qu'en france nos objectifs entre
français même si sa ré évoluer ça y'a
pas si longtemps on peut jouer un peu
avec tout européen maintenant ça reste
limitée mais la période dorée du poker
et quand même derrière nous bouquin
c'est un roman jeunesse sur sur les cinq
sens dystopie dans un bunker
est ce que ça marche la brigade a eu 7 à
la fin ça marche c'est ici on se lance à
la perte du matériel par contre s'est
trompé de sens pour la combinaison car
modèle perd une pièce 11 un monde un peu
je perdre dans cette partie même s'ils
restent limités ont baissé de la jouant
de bullet 11 ans abonde en
reconstruction totale
tu aurais subi les affres de l'humanité
des excès des virus justement c'était
avant avant que le virus n'a rien
j'avais des crises à la pollution
tous les problèmes qu'on peut subir que
c'est plutôt dans le thème d'actualité
je passe une partie va se lancer pour la
dernière minute ou par non mariés de
gosse est d'accord et c'est plus
difficilement concilier avec la vie de
famille le peut car souvent sa tenue
allez on fait un bullet yanaëlle le jul
matin il l'a vu mais sympa le projet set
où il y aura pas mal mais soir était
bout qu'ils éprouvent aussi l alter la
même du coup peut-être j'ai des trucs en
mer j'ai plein de trucs en l'air gh2 ne
mange pas
ouais bah merde c'est fini ok n'a pas eu
le temps de terminer ce but est en tout
cas bravo in hyde qui habillés d'un
petit point devant baron fou bar en full
steam on a fait très mal aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il va vite roi 0-1 bravo à lui
aussi aptitudes le titre good as bravo à
tous elle vous est pas mon tir j'ai été
très généreux j'ai quand même terminé à
la 9e place
éboue top 10 des gens qui n'ont fait que
cette partie qui me sont passés devant
oui mais le crush you tube qui complète
le podium
en tout cas bravo à tous ceux qui quand
même une cinquantaine pour cette
variante
merci au sable mais là aujourd'hui
belhadj de très bons mais en tout cas
c'est très divertissant du coup c'était
la dernière covarel un commentaire ou un
petit moment a priori je n'ai parlé au
tout début et c'est peut-être pas encore
un très bon pote avec plaisir micro et
du coup on va continuer à organiser
quand même de ce tournoi les programmes
et à 13h15
mais ça fait plus tard moi confesse à
contourner un petit peu et du coup on va
peut-être essayer de vous proposer des
choses nouvelles dans les jours à venir
les semaines à venir aura plein de
contenus à vous proposez nous un petit
peu changé la dynamique
donc il y aura moins de stream à 13h 46m
semaines déjà
ce soit vous allez rendez vous à 19h
avec vlad et kevin bien sûr l'écran
autour de vlad pour des parties
pédagogique
j'ai deux mille trois cents à 60 le sam
mais ça c'est pas vu aujourd'hui je sais
pas moi quand est ce que je pourrai
retrouver alors les jeudis soirs et une
arène certainement au delà comme entrer
un abonnement diamant d'ailleurs a gagné
jeudi à 20h30 n'hésitez pas à venir où
il se passe des trucs à le tournoi de
magma
le pion fera dans les ardennes ce truc
entre nous il ya d'autres choses à venir
la jazz comme qui va organiser ça va
commencer à partir de début mai son
premier gros tournoi réservé aux membres
premium
mais quel que soit votre abonnement même
si le moins onéreux
il y aura des prix pour tout le monde
c'est à dire il y aura des prix par
catégorie et l'eau comme dans les hôtels
sont déjà faits les trois premiers mois
de 800 - de milliers le moins de 1200
euros gagneront du cash et ainsi de
suite
donc à partir de mai y aura une arène
comme ça passera tous les dimanches
samedi vérifier nous vous le redire à
d'ici là où tout le monde pour être
récompensé
ça sera sympa et puis et puis on fera
plein de plein d'autres choses dans les
jours à venir surtout pendant ce
confinement pour vous pour être avec
vous au maximum par des trucs ensemble
c'est sympa lamari ce bague
vous avez peut-être vu il ya deux jours
qu'il commença stream un peu avec nous
elle fera des exotiques
ça vous intéresse je crois que c'est
mercredi dans l'après-midi avec avec le
chat est plein de choses à venir
lesquels fab mathieu certainement russie
voilà donc dit merci à tous et à bientôt
je sais pas quand exactement pour moi
mais très vite
portez vous bien ciao merci